une fusée qui décolle en plein milieu du
grand palais à paris ou encore une plage
tropicale recréer de toutes pièces au
même endroit des décors dignes
d'hollywood pour des défilés de mode à
grand déploiement
c'était là la touche karl lagerfeld une
démesure
à l'image de créateurs plus grand que
nature
les lunettes noires en permanence sur le
nez les cheveux blancs attachés en queue
de cheval l'école toujours extravagant
de designers soigne son image et devient
un personnage c'est comme si j'étais je
vais pas me répéter mais comme si j'ai
ma propre marionnette
je joue avec un personnage arrivée à
paris dans les années 50 il fait ses
classes chez bahl mène chez chloé chez
fendi mais c'est à chanel qu'il doit sa
renommée de super stars de la mode une
maison de haute couture qu'il a
complètement transformé
il est venu à la maison chanel s'était
endormi pendant dix ans après la mort de
coco chanel est celui qui a vraiment su
comment utiliser les adn de la maison et
les pousser dans les futures moi quand
j'ai commencé à apprendre je n'ai couru
dix neuf touchés face à ces morts c'est
fini les acquis m'amuser
c'était comme un challenge pour faire ça
de chanel il sait conserver les
classiques
les tailleurs en tweed les sacs à main
mais il y ajoute son grain de folie et
débarrassent la marque de son côté
ringard
son génie et rapidement reconnu comme le
roi midas
il transforme en or tout ce qu'il touche
et habille les plus grandes stars de la
planète à la tête de trois maisons de
couture c'est un travailleur acharné qui
répète inlassablement qu'il ne prendra
jamais sa retraite
alors lorsqu'il n'est pas apparu sur
scène à l'issue de son dernier défilé en
janvier beaucoup se sont inquiétés et
aujourd'hui c'est tout le monde de la
mode qui est en deuil
c'était un génie tout simplement c'était
un génie de la division il disait des
choses il
il inventait des choses et karl était
mais prenez tous et et ressortaient des
merveilles
je vais garder très fort dans mon coeur
l'exemple d'un homme qui a su être un
directeur artistique extraordinaire
c'est le père de tous les directeurs
artistiques
c'est virginie viard son assistant
depuis trente ans chez chanel qui
devrait lui succéder sans vraiment le
remplacer
quant à des funérailles elles sont
aujourd'hui incertaine
le couturier qui était toujours opposé
lui qui préférait disait-il disparaître
comme un animal dans la forêt sans
laisser de traces
ici jean françois bélanger radio-canada
paris